there's always suspicion of large
organizations in immense amounts of
power whether it's a corporation or
government or you know an evil side
where can you get that mutants yeah
especially when they're all working
together hi I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for
reason TV and today we're here at
comic-con with Simon Kinberg he is a
screenwriter and producer on the latest
x-men movie Days of Future past also the
upcoming Xmen apocalypse Fantastic Four
and Star Wars rebels I've come a long
way dude I us to brings together the
x-men we need your help tell me whether
it was the sense you done busy Simon
thanks for taking the time to talk to
every day do x-men it's part of why it's
so successful I would think is how
relatable it is to a wide audience can
you just talk about some of the
relatability that you that's part of
your creative process yeah well I think
with the x-men there's something
inherently relatable to the idea which
is that everybody especially when they
were I think a teenager but in any sort
of stage a life feels a bit of an
outsider feels a little different feels
like they have something that makes them
you know embarrassed or shamed lesser
than and so for everybody there's
something about sort of mutant see that
we can connect to relate to so I think
there is something inherently relatable
about the idea being a mutant and then I
think one of the things they did so well
in the comic and you know we try to do
in the movies is there's different sort
of each stage of life is represented so
you have like the younger kids who are
more the students at Xavier school you
have obviously Xavier who's more you
know grown-up and paternal character you
have Eric magneto who's also slightly
more grown-up paternal character but
also you know messed up and sort of
trying to find his place in the world so
you just you have sort of the whole
pantheon of almost like human experience
can you talk about how from a societal
perspective they do start out you know
as outcasts but society grows to accept
them more or less and we see that
because of the time travel can you talk
about how that might parallel our
society a little yeah well you know I
think obviously being different and
outsider and the sort of majority world
being kind of xenophobic and prejudice
against those people
is something that can stand as a
metaphor for racism for sexism for
anti-semitism for homophobia as I know
specifically for Bryan Singer he's um
you know big gay rights sort of
activists and and the homophobia angle
of it was interesting to him but he's
also Jewish and I think the
anti-semitism was interesting and
magneto is a Jewish character who lost
his parents in the Holocaust so I think
there's there is a sort of again
inherently political aspect to it and
what we tried to create by the end of
days of future past was some sense that
the world a acknowledges that mutants
exist because that really wasn't the
case in the nineteen seventy three of
the former timeline and be that while
there are mutants out there just as
they're humans out there who are
dangerous they're also mutants out there
just as they're humans who can help us
protect us and are just like us yeah can
you talk about how it really comes down
to individualism and there's good and
bad on both sides on the government
mutants every walk of life and it really
boils down to the person and their
choices yeah I mean one of the
interesting things about setting the
movie in the 1970s which was a decision
that was a an arbitrary decision we made
because we could have said it you know
in the 60s when first class took place
we could have said it the 80s and we
chose the 70s because it was a
particularly sort of dark period in
American history because it would happen
with Nixon because of Vietnam and so you
know the movie shows that there are the
sort of the possibility for evil or you
know nefarious activity on human side on
the mutant side and that ultimately
people can change and and meaning you
don't you know just born good and you're
not just born and destined to be bad
professor you never find this hard to
believe I was sent here for you from the
future 50 years from now he's giving me
that one more time please stay with me
in the beginning the Sentinels were just
targeting mutants and they began
targeting everyone on that note with
Nixon and the Sentinel a government
program run amok that storyline is
somewhat popular in these kind of movies
what makes that such a useable plot line
well I think there's always suspicion of
large organizations in immense amounts
of power whether it's a corporation or
government or you know an evil society
where you gather mutants yeah especially
when they're all working together so and
the 70s is a rich time for that because
there was corruption in the government
and there was maybe more pernicious
things happening then even in the 80s
and the 90s and this in this last decade
awesome all thanks thanks again for
taking the time sure of course thank you
friesen TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer
you